My insurance was covered by lab tests. Now they want different codes. Can you provide these?
So if you do your lab tests through us and you have insurance, let's say I have medicare,
let's say, can we provide the code so you can submit to medicare? No, we can't. So you can't,
you cannot submit two insurance through our clinic. So you'll have to go to a practitioner that's local
if you want to submit to insurance. And while that is a provider within your network,
medicare doesn't have necessarily a network, but then you have to go to a provider that accepts medicare
and can, you know, if it's medicare, if it's group health or that, you know, whatever it is,
you have to go to Blue Cross Blue Shield provider doctor. If you have Blue Cross Blue Shield,
you want it to be provided. The doctor that submitting these for me want some kind of documentation
now. If I'm going to have to start paying what tests do I really need or just get the same as before.
So that kind of plays off the first question. How often do you have to get blood tests? Now you can,
you know, if you want to do the least expensive tests that you have to do, you could just run
tests that would be more specific to markers that were elevated. So let's say my CBC and differential
has been normal, you know, let's say I've been getting lab tests every month for the last year.
And now my insurance is blocking at paying for it and I'm going to have to pay on a pocket. And I
don't want to pay $300 a month to run monthly lab tests on a pocket. Can I, can I narrow it down to
just test the things that were abnormal? The answer is yes, you can. So it can become much less expensive.
So as an example, let's say my CBC and differential has been normal the last six months.
The only thing that's been elevated, let's pretend it's alcohol and phosphatase.
Alcohol and phosphatase has been level has been abnormal and it's been elevated. And I am unfendman.
So I do want to keep an eye on it. Can I just run an alcohol and phosphatase test? Well, no, but
you could just run a comprehensive metabolic profile, which would be far less expensive. You could
probably do that for, you know, 50 bucks. And if it's trend, if it's staying level, you might
be able to spread out, you know, the, the, the, the frequency at which you're getting the test done.
So, and again, like the question before about how often a person should get blunt tests,
it depends on a lot of factors, it depends on what you're doing as far as treatment goes, it depends on
how you're feeling, subjective data, it depends on, you know, the levels that were abnormal and to
the jury, those, those tests were abnormal. So we'd have to factor in all those, but you can narrow
down, well, I don't need to run a PSA testing in. My PSA is normal, I don't even have prostate cancer.
So why am I paying for that thing? Yes, we can narrow down and do less things and it can be less expensive.